Yemen's Iran-aligned Houthi movement...
...said it launched missile and drone attacks on a military parade in Aden,...
...the seat of the Saudi-backed government,..
...with the death count now at 40 people including a commander.
The mayor of Somalia's capital Mogadishu has died of wounds...
...sustained in a militant bombing attack on his office last month,...
...according to the government.
Indonesia's Aceh province flogged nearly a dozen people including a Buddhist man,...
...for breaking local Islamic law.
In Mozambique, Mozambican President Filipe Nyusi...
...and Renamo opposition leader Ossufo Momade sign a landmark agreement...
...to formally end decades of hostilities in the southern African country.
Finally from Saudi Arabia, the United States believes that Hamza bin Laden,...
...a son of slain al-Qaida leader Osama bin Laden and himself.....
...a notable figure in the militant group, is dead, according to an official.